(soft music)
- I am a wealthy teen.
- I'm a wealthy teen.
(classical music)
- What does everyone's parents do?
- My dad is a senior manager for a cool,
like, computer tech company.
- My mom works for NBC and
my dad works for DirecTV.
- I actually don't have a dad.
My mom, when she was 35,
she decided that she-
she didn't need a man and, you know,
she went through sperm donation.
She opened up a business
for cancer patients
for, like, areola replacement
and permanent cosmetics.
- She said her mom was single and a lot
of single parents oftentimes
struggled a little bit more.
That's not the case for
every single parent, but.
My mom's a psychiatric technician
and my dad is a farrier.
So, like, he does horse shoes on horses.
- My mom owns a beauty
salon, so she does something,
like, similar to you what your mom does.
And then my dad, I don't
know how to explain his job
but he's like the manager
of a school district, so.
- Cool.
- They mentioned that their
mom owned a hair salon.
There's a possibility of
that having unsteady income.
- What cars do you guys' parents drive?
- I have a Lexus, a BMW and a Volvo.
- My mom drives a Tesla and
my dad has like a, I don't-
like, kind of like a Jeep,
but like not really a Jeep.
I don't really know what it's called.
- My mom was driving a 2003 Dodge Ram
with like 200,000 miles on it,
but she just got a Mercedes yesterday.
(applause)
- Go mom.
I live in a beach town.
Cars aren't like super important
to us, but my dad is really
into motorcycles, so he drives motorcycle.
- I own three BMWs so my car,
both my parents' cars are,
we're all like BMW lovers, so.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- [Producer] There's been a tie.
- Oh.
- [Producer] Abby and Jun.
You guys have 60 seconds to pitch.
- I grew up, I moved a lot
of places cause my dad's
really career driven.
I grew up in Connecticut.
I live really close to the beach
and that's like my passion.
I grew up going on vacations every year.
I'm very well traveled.
We could talk about that if you want.
I can talk about that.
Do you wanna hear or no?
Is that 60 seconds?
(laughs)
- We weren't always wealthy,
so I, I, I don't know what else
to say.
Like yeah, we go on vacations a lot.
I have aspirations to be a doctor.
My parents have put me to be a doctor.
They both went to college.
We're really privileged, thankfully.
(dramatic music)
(buzzer)
- Bye.
- I was like really quiet.
So I think that's kind of
what made everyone vote me
out so easily.
- So it was a tie last round,
and just outta curiosity, what
reason did you, between Jun
and I, did you think was
inherently poor or low income?
Like how did you judge that
based off of knowing us for five minutes?
- I think my dad always ingrained
into my brain that like, people
who drive motorcycles are
like really unsafe, and
they like, that's really
that's not a good decision to make.
I'm like "Okay, Dad."
- I have a question for you.
- Yes.
- Did you go to private school?
- Yeah, I went to private
school when I was younger
and then I moved to public school only
because like when I moved houses there
wasn't any like good
private schools near me.
And also I really like
my, like, public high
school experience.
- Do you go to public or private school?
- Public.
- Okay.
- I think prior to this
year, I think I went
to a lot of like stereotypical
like rich kids schools.
When I was in elementary they,
we were starting like iPad,
we had like iPads in like first grade.
And then in third grade we
started having like Chromebooks.
Like, I have like a lot
of friends just, like,
like, a lot of different districts.
And then they all were like,
they only started getting
Chromebooks when they were
in like fifth grade.
- She kept talking about Chromebooks.
I was like, is she
trying to, like, take us
to a different direction
about Chromebooks?
So I was like, okay, I
don't wanna know about
Chromebooks, so.
- I went to East Catholic,
which was a public school
or private school.
- So I go to a public
school because my mom
didn't wanna drive me super
far to go to private school.
- Yeah, there were, like, all
like an hour away and my mom was not
about to drive me an
hour away to for school.
- So I went to an
academy for middle school
and then now I'm in a public high school.
It's close to the beach
and it has programs for the
science stuff that I like.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
- [Producer] There was
another tie this round
so there will be another tie breaker round
with a 60 second pitch.
And this time it is
between Chandra and Abby.
- So I actually, you know,
make a lot of my own money by myself.
My mom, she really wants to, like, stress
financial independence.
So I'm actually a content creator.
I, my main platform is TikTok
and I do a lot of like fashion
and like modeling content.
Last year I learned how to like work
with brands and like make
a lot of money from that,
which you can make a lot of
money if you guys are interested
in social media, definitely get into it.
- Forgot to mention that we also vacation
if that means anything to you in Europe,
in like Scotland and stuff
because a lot of my
family lives out there.
I also create content.
I love video games.
I don't have a job myself
cause I'm really focused on academics,
but doing something like you talked
about doing would be really cool.
I'm not the mole.
(ding)
I promise you.
(upbeat music)
- [Producer] And for the
first time today we have
a second tie.
- Oh my gosh.
(gasping)
- [Producer] Why don't you guys
huddle for a second and come
up with one question to ask both of them?
- Okay.
(dramatic music)
(teens discussing)
- So what college do you want to go to?
- Oh yes.
- And do your parents plan on funding it?
- So yes, they're gonna fund it.
I'm not gonna lie, I don't
really know how much it works
because with my parents
it's never been an issue.
Like they've always been very clear
that like we're really lucky
and we have the ability to support you
in whatever you wanna do
which is why they're not
hard on me for my grades.
My dream school is UCSB, or
I really wanna study abroad
in like Europe or Asia
or something like that.
- Who funds your college?
- Okay, so I'm actually on full
ride to USC on QuestBridge,
which is like a scholarship
for people in Connecticut,
like local, a local scholarship.
- Do you pay for like everything else,
like, daily expenses or like?
- Yes, yeah I do.
Yeah, I've been working
since I was 15 as well.
Like I was working in a restaurant
when I was in Connecticut.
Yeah, and then I started, you know,
actually making like
money, money from brands.
(bell rings)
- We decided to vote Chandra out.
No hard feelings.
- Can I give you hug?
- I would've still voted for
Abby if I'm being honest.
But then he typed out
like this long paragraph
- I had been voting for
Chandra since the beginning
and I feel like she had
known what the value
of a dollar was because
she saw her mom struggle
and she wanted to make a
better life for herself
because her mom stressed
that Chandra needed to
be financially independent
to live a better life.
And then everyone kind
of just agreed with that.
- Hope you guys get the mole.
(laughter)
- I think they voted me
out because I said, like,
that it was through scholarship.
Like why would she need a
scholarship if she has so
much money?
And that like I have a high work ethic,
so I think that's why.
- [Producer] If you wanna keep
playing, raise your hand on
three.
One, two, three.
- Nevermind.
- If the box turns green,
you guys successfully
voted the mole out and you guys
win the cash prize together.
If the box turns red, the
mole is still amidst you guys
and they win the entire
cash prize to themselves.
(dramatic music)
(cheering)
- [Producer] I'm going to
count to three and on three the
mole is going to reveal themselves, okay?
(classical music)
(upbeat music)
(laughing and celebrating)
- Yeah, so I've grown up
like low income, you know,
my whole life QuestBridge
is actually a scholarship
which I am on full ride
for low income students who
are like high achieving.
Like it's also been hard
because it's like my mom,
she, you know has gone
through like substance abuse.
Like we lived in a motel room and
with like all of our animals
and you know, we had to like
We had to like-
- We're here to support you.
Yeah.
- All this stuff in, like, my life,
I've just grown to be like
really grateful for, you know
and just like not take
anything for granted.
- No, like, that's so awesome.
(laughing and cheering)
(upbeat music)